so apparently I'm stressed out this week
my stomach has been going crazy insane
pains what kind of pain how'd this a few
feels like this yeah not not constant
doesn't go away not like sharp but just
doesn't go away and I thought I had food
poison or something but I'm not throwing
up and anyway no issues so finally
decided today on Thursday microrna
Thursday I had a really important call
this morning or hanging out with Stephen
Kelly and then I canceled the rest of I
had a whole day pack like meetings and
calls and hangouts just cancel the whole
thing and thought I can barely stand up
so I decided to go see the doctor I went
to the doctor and she asked me a whole
bunch of questions and a whole bunch of
tests I had to do an ultrasound did you
do after didn't alter sir where did you
go close what just a block South there's
an ultrasound place because I went to
the doctor and she's like I can't see
anything wrong with you physically she
asked me all these questions she
examined all the stuff and then then
she's like okay she'd go do an
ultrasound to see if there's anything
that I can't see and you have to sound
guys like you're fine nothing nothing's
wrong he told you right away yeah I said
well they tell you if it's like a anyway
I was talking about chatting yeah okay
so so the doctor told me that it's
stress that I'm too stressed out in that
it's causing me stomach issues yeah in
the last few days you were like you
couldn't sleep at night you woke I know
one night you were what you were up late
and the other night that you're you're
thinking about your work this has never
happened to me before I don't I've never
had this stomach by went to the docs
like I don't even know I've never had
this before and I have a lot of work
happening but I also enjoy my work you
know like I find happiness in my work
did I find fulfillment I work I was
thinking about it I was thinking about
why I think it's because I've taken on
so many people under the leadership
stuff like I don't mind the usual work
the website the book the youtube channel
tds it's usually not that like it's a
lot but I can hand
a lot but recently been working with a
number of people on the under leadership
and helping them become more visionary
and you know take the next step up in
their lives and their careers and when i
first started i only had a couple and
then i expanded it to more people and i
feel like i might be too much i feel
like i care too much i feel like you
know when somebody isn't growing as much
as I feel like they should grow it
affects me emotionally so you don't need
to like not take on as many people or
care less that sounds really bad no but
that's not you what do you not me
careless i know i don't know i don't i
don't know capping you should not take
on that many task i don't know i don't
know but but yet it brings me that's the
that's the best part of what I do when
I'm when I'm soon when I see somebody
and they're growing and getting better
it makes me like the most fulfilled of
anything that I do but it's stressing me
out and causing me stomach pains so I
spent the rest of the day just relaxing
and not doing any email or anything and
I feel a little bit better so I'm
probably gonna I don't know I have to
chill for a little bit i gotta chill for
a little bit we gotta chill and feel
better and then figure 2 point what you
kept looking at me you should talk to
the camera well but i'm telling you as
i'm like you see you in the camera so
yeah i'm gonna relax for a bit what are
you laughing Evan goes into time i heard
self imposed time out so if i'm not as
fast as I'm not usually pretty fast
anyway on email and stuff but if I'm
slower than normal it's because I'm
relaxing and what why is your finger if
you kept looking at me what what's I
like looking at my wife can tell you why
after why tell the tell the people cuz
you just ate chicken in your spread
smells oh so the camel
hahaha you bought me the chicken your
body injuring water dude do I smell like
chicken ah kid stuff it oh look my shirt
10 grand so reach me on Facebook because
it's going to be the only way for the
next little bit that I think I'm going
to uh I'm gonna respond the stuff and
then as I use into it off I'll figure
things out because the doctors like you
need to stop doing what you're doing so
but I can't cuz I love it and I love you
too hmm okay what's your final message
you're fine Emma snow your video also
stress out don't stress me out say your
final visit take it easy take it easy
don't stress out don't stress it life is
simple life is simple believe believe
believe believe what we should do it
together okay believe